من بعد كمل الاعمال اللي تكلمنا عنها
واستضفنا نجومها وتابعناها احنا كمان
شخصيا حبينا السنه نكرر تجربه استفتاء
النقاد اللي عملناه السنه الماضيه وسالنا
مجموعه من النقاد عن ارائهم في الاعمال
الدراميه في هذا الموسم خلونا نسمع سوا
مين برايي النقاد كان افضل ممثل وافضل
ممثله
افضل مثل ما زال قصي خوري هو نجم الشباك
باسم يخور في العربجي وعبد فات فيه النار
بالنار الفنان خالد النبوي للدور الصعب
والمريء بالتفاصيل في مسلسل رساله الامام
فضلت مسلسل زنت فوجدت ان تيم حسن هو
الاكثر ادهاشا على مستوى الوطن العربي في
في دور
القصبي
وجورج خباز وفايز قزح وجاسم النبهان اختار
الفنان اللبناني جورج خباز بمسلسل النار
بالنار والفنان العبد فهد ايضا عن نفس
المسلسل والفنان دياب بمسلسل تحت الوصايه
في محمد رمضان وخالد النبوي لكن في رايي
برضو افضل ممثل هو محمد رمضان قادر يمشي
مع الشخصيه بتدعيتها
بكل حاجه
[موسيقى]
حقيقه منى زكي عن دورها في مسلسل تحت
الوصايه
خليني اضيف ايضا ورد الخالدي للموت ثلاثه
منى زكي عن تحت الوصايه وجدت النائمين
خليل استطع ان تقدم اداء متميزا
منى زكي
ومنى واصل
وهي عبد السلام الى منازع منى زكي اكيد
والفنانه السوريه كارثه بشار عن دور مريم
في النار بالنار وورد الخال عن دورها في
مسلسل للموت 3 حنان مطاوع في ووسخيه ثم في
النص التاني من رمضان جات منى زكي تحت
الوصايه
راى النقاد في افضل الممثلين المساعدين
[موسيقى]
عبد الرحمن يماني ومؤيد الثقفي محمد اكبر
ثابته
وحسين الحداد الفنان فتحي عبد الوهاب
بشخصيتين مهمين في سوق الكانتو والكتيبه
101 الفنان احمد عيد وهو ايضا من يعني
العناصر المميزه هذا الموسم في عمله نادره
شخصيه مسعود الفنان دياب في شخصيه صالح في
تحت الوصايه انا سياره بالزنا الذئب
العاصي الشامي من مسلسل
تحيا المسلسل جعفر العمده من غير ما افكر
اقدر اقول الفنان حمزه العيلي في مسلسل
الامام الشافعي
انس طياره كان يعني ممثل استطاع ان يقدم
اداء متميزا في دوره نورس باشا في مسلسل
[موسيقى]
الزهراني
بشاير سلطان
وساره صلاح مي كساب افضل ممثل دور تاني في
مسلسل جعفر العمده والفنانه مها نصار عن
ادوارها التلاته وخصوصا تحت الوصايا
فنانه الجميله مي كساب لدى توحيد في مسلسل
سفر الممثل السعوديه وايضا الممثله
السعوديه ريم العلي في مسلسل من هو ولدنا
ايضا استطاعه ان تقدم اداء وانا اجدها ان
هي افضل
يعني افضل ممثله في المسلسل بالكامل
اعمال كثيره ضخمه انتاجيا واخرى جماهيريا
ومجهودات جباره خلتنا كمان نسال النقاد
اصحابنا مين برايهم كان افضل مخرج
[موسيقى]
سامر البرقاوي
وكريم الشناوي
وعلي بدر رضا وخالد الحلفاوي ليش حقه في
مسلسل
الامام الشافعي
في مسلسل سفر برلك
محمد شاكر خضير مخرج مسلسل تحت الوصايه
بلا شك يعني يقدم هذه الملحمه التاريخيه
في مسلسل سفر برلك بالتاكيد يستحق ان يكون
هو افضل مخرج
بس انا كمان كانت مليئه بضيوف شرف نجوم
غير متوقعين بادوار ثانويه نجمت بشكل واسع
عن كل هذولا وغيرهم سالنا النقاد مين
برايهم افضل واكبر مفاجاه في رمضان السنه
[موسيقى]
المفاجاه حقيقه هي عوده
ناصر قصبه عبد الله السدحان بعد انقطاع 12
سنه
بالنسبه لالي الفنان طارق تميم الذي عاد
الى العمل بعد انقطاع سبع سنوات وايضا
الفنانه والمذيعه
الموسم مسلسل جعفر العمده بلغه الكره
القدم الريمونتادا التي يعني حققها محمد
رمضان مع محمد سامي هذا النجاح غير
المتوقع وغير المسبوق حتى بالمقارنه
بنجاحهم في الاسطوره اعتقد ان هو يعني
المسلسل اللي الناس هتفتكر الموسم بجعفر
العمده كان مفاجاه للكثيرين على كل
المستويات مفاجاه الموسم كله
الفنانه هاله صدقي هاله صدقي عامله دور
مهم دايما بتطلع ارستقراض لكن طالعه بلدي
بشكل جميل فيها الكوميديا وفيها الاكشن
فيها كل اللي احنا بنقول التوابل بتاعتها
من بعيد كده بتفكرنا بزينه بالنسبه له هو
ممثل السعوديه عبد الرحمن اليماني يعني
وجدت ممثل لدي طاقه عاليه طاقه ادائيه
عاليه ممكن ان يكون يعني في المستقبل
الفنان له يشار له بالبنان
بنجي لعند الفعل اهم افضل عمل خلينا نسمع
ايش قالو
[موسيقى]
واخيرا
لقصي خولي ونادين
وايضا مسلسل جعفر العمده لكني
عميل الى واخيرا
من الافضل لجراه طرحه السياسي وسقف العالي
السابعه
وكامل العقل وبلغ نهائي مسلسل تحت الوصايا
رغم ان هو اتعرض في النصف الثاني لكن قدر
ان هو يحقق نجاح كبير لكن بالتاكيد من
المسلسلات النصف الاول الصفاره والعرش
السبعه
وعمله نادره اعمال ايضا تستحق ان تتقدم
على المستوى الفني ابتسم ايها الجنرال
مسلسل خارج التصنيف لا ينافس اي مسلسل اخر
مسلسل ايضا تحت الوصايه لمنى زكي هو مسلسل
النار بالنار افضل مسلسل السنه دي هو جعفر
العمده
وافضل هذه المسلسلات
كل ما كان فيه الحلو في الاقل جوده
والنقاد في الكليب الجيحي سمعوكم ارائهم
في الفنانين اللي كانوا الاسوا برايهم في
رمضان
[موسيقى]
اسوا ممثل بالتاكيد هم كثر يعني
مقارنه مع
الجيدين في الساحه
الرمضانيه لكن اعتقد انه احمد ايراج لم
يحالف الحظ في مسلسل حياه المثاليه اسف
مضطرين ندي محمد سعد جائزه اسوا ممثل لسوء
تقدير وسوء استعداده لهذا الدور لم يحقق
اي نجاح يذكر السعودي
فيما يخص اسماء ممثل فهم كثر ولكن انا
بختار صالح بكري من مسلسل تغيير جو والذي
يقوم بدور فارس لم يترك لم نشعر به محمد
سعد هو الاسوا السنه
[موسيقى]
مريم الغامدي لم يحالفها الحظ ايضا في
مسلسل حياه المثاليه لم يشفع لها هذا
التاريخ العريض جدا الذي قدمته في الساحل
الفنيه
يعني هذا
العام اسوا ممثله الفنانه ريهام حجاج لم
تقنع اي حد
بالبطوله اللي هي بتعملها
وهذه كانت ارائهم في العمل الاسوا
[موسيقى]
ق مسلسل على ما يبدو دفعه لندن اسوا مسلسل
بطوله محمد سعد محدش بيسمعني اما اسوا عمل
فهو مسلسل
واخيرا
عمل سيء جدا ولا يستحق ان يعرض لانه لم
يقدم اي جديد
طبعا هذه اراء النقاد واحنا نحب نشكر كل
اللي ظهروا معانا في هذه الفقره وشاركونا
بارائهم وهم عبد الرحمن الناصر ليلى احمد
ومحمد عبد الرحمن واحمد سعد الدين ورحاب
ظاهر وفاطمه عبد الله وعباس حايك شكرا
جزيلا لهم من تفاعلكم
مشاهدينا احنا السنه كمان حبينا نعمل شيء
مختلف يعني وبدل ما بس نسال النقاد حبينا
كمان نسالكم انتم مشاهدينا وعبر كل
منصاتنا سالناكم مين برايكم انتم كان
الافضل سالناكم في كل مكان فيسبوك تويتر
انستجرام كله يعني والافضل برايكم كان في
فئه افضل ممثل في المراتب الاولى او
الثلاثه الاولى جاء محمد رمضان عن جعفر
العمده باسم ياخور عن العربجي ومكسيم خليل
عن ابتسم ايها الجنرال لكن الاصوات الاعلى
راحت للنجم محمد رمضان اللي اخترتوه افضل
ممثل في الموسم وبالنسبه لافضل ممثله في
المراتب الثلاثه الاولى كانت في كاريس
بشار عن النار بالنار هاله صدقي عن جعفر
العمده ومنى زكي عن تحت الوصايه والاصوات
الاغلب راحت للنجمه منى زكي اللي بتقدم
اداء مبهر حقيقه والدليل انه اصلا المسلسل
دخل سباق في النصف الثاني من رمضان ومتصدر
الترند والمشاهدات والاشادات اما افضل
مسلسل فباغلبيه كبيره جدا وصراحه زي ما
توقعنا جعفر العمده في المركز الاول كافضل
مسلسل بحسب ارائكم
[موسيقى]